well let's talk about President Obama
and some poll numbers as long as we're
talking about Ukraine cuz he's getting
hit basically on both sides people
saying he's not doing enough he's doing
too much so a new CNN or C international
poll came out about Obama's numbers 57
percent believe leaders of other
countries no longer respect Obama 50%
see Obama as the strong and decisive
leader 50% do not there's also a roughly
50/50 split on whether Obama inspires
confidence
53% say he's tough enough to handle a
crisis and 77 percent say he's likable
let's start with the likable part
because that that is right like that's
the thing this guy this was a cult of
personality that we all voted for I
voted for him twice hope and change we
all still like him sort of more than
policies is that fair to say numbers
high though isn't it that's a high we
don't take that I take that in my own
family no I think he's I think he's
still incredibly likable you know he's
that he's opened the white house up to
be an accessible place and that family
seems to be one that everybody really
loves and respects you know it's the
other numbers but I think I've seen
vegetables on that's true except for the
vegetables and the bike helmets and mom
jeans it's a pretty normal American
family but I've you know it's the rest
of the numbers that I think are
problematic for for sure I mean I mean
look it I think and I say this a lot
when you look at the numbers about what
people think about him as a person as a
leader I think it really boils down to
the fact that they just hate him they've
hated him since before he was
inaugurated the first time and so to me
those numbers don't really mean anything
because for one every president's
numbers do this over the course of their
presidency but I mean for him he's has
such a tougher mountain to climb when
you face opposition before you even
swear into office so how do you measure
the effectiveness of a man who's
constantly being blocked like how do I
know what works and what doesn't if I've
never seen anything through really I
mean so the important number isn't the
77% the likable number but it's the
other percent which is the the hate
number is so it's so big Lee do you
think it's about 23 percent that just
hate him no matter what it's probably
you
you think that's I think that's probably
the bare minimum absolutely I would I
would say that's a given and then you
you look at the fact that they obstruct
him for the simple fact of obstructing
and so it's hard for me to judge him as
a leader when I haven't really seen him
lead I mean at least when Bush was
president the Democrats would okay you
want to do this we don't like it but
we'll see it through we will see it
through there's something they have play
along right let's play along a little
bit for the sake of not shutting down
the government later and so I can't
really say with 100% certainty how I
feel about his leadership or his
decisiveness but for one who the
are we to talk about the decisiveness of
the President of the United States like
you know we don't work that job it's
like who are you sitting on your
accounts like yeah man that Obama guy no
matter even if it's like even if it's a
Republican like you don't know how hard
it is to be president no matter what
party he really doesn't get a chance to
give you a poll number and how you do
your job the way you made those fries 33
percent I mean I've had better fries in
other other times but I don't really I
mean I do know that Obama's a big fan of
the show and has clicked like many times
on a lot of likeable other somebody on
YouTube named Barack Obama just felt
slightly differently do you think so to
that point do you think he gives a
flying about numbers at this point
especially because he's almost entering
lame duck status if he's not already
there I just saw this morning that
already they're planning this move to
Hillary already with some of his people
and Biden's already pissed about that so
do you think he cares he looked for
these numbered he's he like I got two
and a half years left or whatever it is
and I think do it hello I think he sees
this that 77% number and he's happy
about that but I think he totally I mean
how could you not care when you get
numbers coming out all the time that
says you're you know ineffective or your
wimpy or you wear mom jeans or whatever
it is that the 23% level against all the
time yeah you got a and you can't punch
anyone no you have to take it like yeah
they're calling you out you have to sit
there and take it
just like bitchslaps Biden every now and
again there's something so I hope he has
a punching bag or something in the
office he's write to me that number
that's interesting is that 57 post about
which was there you know they were
saying what was it 57% of Americans
believe that other leaders find him
wimpy or weak or what is that number is
crazy how do you even determine that
number how to CNN even find out was it
not a hundred like because they are the
leaders of course they're going to think
that the other leader is a week or a
wimp like it was gonna come on and go
man that Obama he's so strong and so
confident I wouldn't want that guy yeah
I would never want to fight that guy I
mean who we love you Obama with like
they take the pole against other world
leaders instead of witches middle
Americans think the President of Uganda
poll the leader it's not an interesting
number somebody in Minnesota saying like
I bet like the President of Uganda
thinks he's not very strong like who
cares so they don't even know right so
isn't this one of these things that goes
back to the Ukraine thing where it's
like he's damned if he does damned if he
doesn't because you can do more and then
they'll respect him more but then we'll
be in a war so it's like Maddie a pic do
I want to be in a war I don't want to be
in or do I want to be liked right now
and that's that's a tough choice I think
the number would be interesting if it
just said 57 Americans can name another
world leader that would be the real
number two okay